good morning woke up in grandma's house
and it's absolute best i get to sleep in
because um techa likes to sleep with
grandma
ah so it's the best i get to wake up and
y'all might laugh but
this is [ __ ] okay
um i get to wake up at
6 30.
i know i get to sleep in because this
bull likes to wake up at 5 30 sometimes
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
granted i have been waking up at four
but that's a whole different story
so you could see him
and grandma
look at him he's taking off his peaches
and he's getting dressed for the day
grandma got the time for his [ __ ]
she's trying to help him
okay so i'm getting my hair done today
and honestly
i have a lot of white hair um it's a
genetic thing it's both on my mom's side
and my dad's head so i started getting
white hair like a lot
in like my mid-20s
and then it just freaking went nuts the
older i got
so like let's
actually color it oh here
so like
hello focus on
my hand focus on my hand look at the man
there we go
oh you can't really see it this way yeah
but i have it all around the crown
here
and it's the absolute worst i have to
get it done literally every two weeks
it's like a guy haircut but minus the
haircut and it's more so
covering my roots i have to do that
every two weeks it is what it is
um but i've just been getting tired of
my hair
and it's not so much my hair i think
it's just me that just either doesn't
okay i was gonna say i don't have time
to do it
but if i cared about it
i would make time so that just tells me
i don't care about it
so i don't know if i should leave it
long because i literally never do [ __ ]
with my hair i've let it grown and i
just let this thing happen which is like
an air dry
and it just ate the vibe like it's just
not cute and then when i want to get
cute i never know what to do with it so
instead of just letting it grow
and do absolutely nothing i'm thinking
of
cutting it
and making it super chic and my head is
going to be super chic
will it turn out to be super chic
only
god knows that uh answer but
i hear footsteps
hey cutie what stomach and nick had this
dominic and derek are your cousins huh
and they have that
yeah
well we'll see what i decide i'm kind of
on the fence i'm
leaning
bless you
i'm leaning
more on the chop it off side i'll
um
and make it like not really pink but
just like lift up the pink that's here
and just kind of like make it more pink
at the tips
okay you guys
so i want
to get my hair done
and then it was such a rush day so i
went to get my hair done
then immediately after came home to pick
tyka up
and then oh went straight to a
children's birthday party it's our
friend anna and jeremy's um daughter's
one-year birthday party so we saw david
and christina
um bart didn't get to go because he was
filming jk news and so did joe
um and then from there we went straight
to jk news because
that little man over there was on an
episode
but let me just show you something
before i show you my hair because i kind
of
went nuts
so i recorded a video and i'm going to
show you the video
let me see
you guys ready for this
get the volume up
okay here we go
here's the video
[Music]
i'm
yep so that was yesterday that's what i
did
and i don't show you today because like
i wash my face and have like mascara
there
okay fine i'll show you
and it looks all jacked up now but
this
is
the do this is the hair
so it's kind of like this yellow
orange
mix here with like white streaks
it doesn't look cute
without my face being down and it being
way super straight but because i don't
like it to curve it i want it to be
super straight but yes
this is the do
the goal is to go completely
white
um so i have one more session in about
two weeks
but yeah
it's done
okay so the
inspiration behind it was you guys saw
my hair in the last clip it was just
so boring and i'm uh i guess i'm more of
a creative person
um
so like i feel
the need to change constantly or like
add things try i don't know i just feel
like
i gotta keep
butterflying you know what i mean like
cocooning and butterflying
so yeah so for a minute um
i just i'm not a hair person i never
know what to do with my hair and i like
i only know how to straighten it and i
know that's super damaging for the hair
so i hadn't straightened it in forever i
just don't do anything with my hair you
guys see i let it air dry and then it
just kind of lucky for me i have texture
my hair that's wavy
um but besides that it's all i had to go
in for me and sometimes it just didn't
look cute but sometimes it works and
sometimes i look cute but
um
yeah i just wasn't happy with it i was
bored with it so i figured it would be
easier to just chop it off and get like
a
permanently uh
like a
straight perm on it so that i could just
take a shower and let it air dry and
it'll dry straight like this so i didn't
get the perm this time around because i
just wanted my hair to
go through this process and kind of just
chill for a bit
um before adding more products to it but
dude i'm so happy with how it feels like
none of my hair is burnt
or any of that i've had really bad
um
situations with my hair when i wanted to
bleach it in the past and it would be
breaking off or it was like gummy
i think i found the hair stylist of my
dreams she's in glendora lux salon
uh rhianne check her out if you're like
dark hair
um and people have been [ __ ] up your
hair
rhiann is the jam
but yeah so far i'm really happy with it
um
at first i was like oh my god i'm gonna
look like he-man so luckily i didn't get
any
bangs done
um but i like it i like it i think it's
fun i think it's gonna like give me like
this weird
edginess that like
i can already see is gonna do so many
different
things to my look and i'm excited
because like
i feel like on my own muse sometimes
like i
i like
playing dress up and like
i get inspired
by like being tall or having certain
features to do certain things so i'm
gonna play around and see what you know
what stuff i can come up with but so far
it's been fun and the feedback's been
pretty cool
um you guys online liked it so thank you
we'll see what i what i what i do with
it i know that the colors everyone
starts talking about ooh i can already
see you adding a bunch of colors
um not sure i'm there yet i think i want
to enjoy
this color for now so if at least for
the next two weeks i'll leave it this
way
and then i'll
lighten it up a little bit more
and we'll take it from there and see
where
the wind takes it
and also it's not that serious of
[ __ ] hair
so i never feel like i can mess with my
hair
um other than it breaking or damaging
but like when it comes to a cut or color
i'm like it's not a big deal i'm not
that attached to my hair and i know some
people are because i have gorgeous hair
and i get it
but me personally
i don't like it
so i just postmated i shouldn't say
post-meeting because i'm not even
postmates i just thor dashed
some
blackbeard diner breakfast this morning
because it's just like a
good old american diner type food but
it's like a little bit more elevated at
least i feel like it is um antagonism
said he wanted waffles so i'm like oh
perfect they have waffles there
um so he's like mom
because it was a few minutes he's like
mom where are my waffles and i'm like oh
they're gonna deliver eagles
no i want grandma's waffles and i'm like
what do you mean what are grandma's
waffles the ones in the freezer he's
talking about egg waffles and i'm like
yo those are gross dude and he starts
crying because he wants those so we'll
see
how he reacts when he gets his waffles
delivered
it just sounds so spoiled already
how he reacts when he gets delivered and
how dramatic he's gonna get about not
having frozen waffles
i'm creative i've created a monster
i'm well aware
i'm well aware
okay guys i guess she's out here
for
breakfast thank you mama
oh you don't care this is okay
you're welcome
well dang i just got molded and i'm
happy i got molded okay
hey excuse me
okay
yeah so what do you think of my hair
i think here's cuny what does that mean
it means that if that's what you like
then
um that's what you got
what is that you know the first thing
that woman over there said to me
i didn't she didn't even open the door
she probably said the truth she didn't
even open the door
actually i recognized you from the
screen
no that well that sounds just as bad she
goes she goes what have you done what
have you done in english that's what i'm
saying what have you done ah what have
you done what did you do
what have you done what have you done
okay remember the side when she said
shake that all out yeah same thing who
do you think shaped it for me i'm not
asking that's disgusting bart shaved it
for me i did throw up after
oh
he's dead
hey ma
people online say that they miss you
they miss you hiding
i am hiding now
they say that they miss you
well tell them thank you
for having me
okay it's been a blessing for them to be
after you
okay you said how do you really feel and
pepper honestly i don't really care you
could shave your head i don't care i
just love you so much it doesn't really
matter i just i'm just happy that you're
happy
uh with what you have
because you're the one that has to live
with it damn you sound like our parents
and so if that's those are the type of
you literally have to live with it too
decisions that you want to wait you just
said to record you because you're going
to say the truth and now you're [ __ ]
up again i love you i said i love you so
much i care about you so much i'm not
even limited by a physical appearance
how beautiful
you are inside i'm so in love but i'm
talking about on the outside
um you're the one that has to
to like live day to day mirror to mirror
you know
interaction to like interaction with
your
with what whatever you call
that
and so if that's what you that's the
type of so you want to put yourself and
drag yourself through i think that's
perfectly fine okay thank you so much
i love you and i don't care what you do
when i don't drive don't get happy
that's too long
look at that her food's just been
sitting there
she's not eating
tech are you eating
okay are you guys done playing with your
camera
all right now i'm in home depot looking
for some moving and packing supplies
so my dad has already either a given
away all of this furniture or sold at
all because as you guys know he's moving
to vegas which is super cool but while
me and ma bear were at my dad's house i
think last week or two weeks ago he
still had a two pieces of furniture left
and they're really cool like one of them
is like this full marble full granite
coffee table to me it looks old i'm like
oh that's just like some old asian
furniture and then jio saw it shows dude
this kind of stuff is coming in again
and it's expensive because it's real you
know it's like that type of lifetime
furniture where you buy once it'll last
like 50 years so that's the type of
person my dad is like he just wants to
buy once crying once so he has a legit
coffee table made out of marble probably
needs to be polished because it's been
there since i was in high school so it's
over 20 years old and he also has a
dining table that's also made out of
marble granite and
he couldn't give those away or he
couldn't sell it or something like that
so what we're thinking
is we'll pack it up and if we can find a
place to put it either in one of our
offices or in a house awesome but if not
we'll just hold on to it and until my
dad moves then we just give it back to
him so i'm trying to find like some
materials
that'll keep his stuff
safe because it is pretty heavy duty so
i do got bungee cords in my truck which
is cool but i want some bubble wrap or
actually you know what's better than
bubble wrap probably for something that
heavy
those blue packing blankets so i was
looking at this
but i think this is for like lightweight
stuff so if i were to get bubble wrap i
need at least something that's
oh like this yeah like thicker
so this would work pretty good
this one's what 33 bucks for a roll for
24 by 100
hmm my asian side is kind of telling me
i should get the blue blanket because
that's what if i get two of those that's
like
60 bucks and you can't really reuse it
the blue blanket
it's so uh versatile like i've used it
to paint i've used to do so many other
things
so i'm gonna go take a look to see oh
there it is right here yeah premium
moving blanket extra large
40 bucks so what do you guys think
40 bucks wait 80 square feet that's huge
i just need 40 square feet that's what
six feet
times just under seven
or should i get something that's like
that's pretty big
either way though
i always feel like it's better to get
something bigger huh
yeah i'll get this so i'll get two of
these guys
because if i get two of those guys
that's still
in the long run i think will be cheaper
right because this is what
40 bucks so it's 80 bucks compared to
compared to 64 bucks but i can reuse
this over and over and over
and i'm thinking i'll go with the bigger
one because if it's too big i could
always fold it in half and just double
layer it
all right so i'm gonna do that get to
them you guys think two is enough
oh well we'll wing it
for some reason something in me is
telling me i should get
the standard moving blanket too it's
only 10 bucks
it's way smaller
but i feel like i could use these two
big ones to cover the main pieces
of furniture because the dining table
and the coffee table is kind of big
but then you might need something just
to wedge in or a sandwich between two
pieces of furniture
and i'm thinking since it's a small one
it might be helpful
to have one of these guys
and just keep it in my truck
you know what i mean oh this is black
one
no this is not reusable
what is it just felt
no i need something i like the blue one
oh man oh yeah i shoot this off on the
picture
i want something that's blue like this
that i can just keep in my truck seat
you just never know
yeah i'll get one of these guys you just
never know
if you guys see the back of my truck i
have all kinds of just in case stuff
because
man you just never know especially if
you're the head of the household you
want to protect your family
and especially like even in a group like
i'm one of the leaders people count on
me for stuff so i just want to be
prepared for everything now
i have to get a wood d squeaker
so so far i asked two people didn't know
where i could find a wood d squeaker and
no one knows where to go and i'm like
don't you guys have like old furniture
where the two pieces of wood are rubbing
against each other
eat
and maybe this furniture is just
old-fashioned or no one uses it anymore
but no one knows where to go so i'm just
walking around
looking for it i am in the lumber
section right you see lumber right there
and i saw like tubes
so i'm just kind of going based off
instinct
there is also a bunch of other i don't
know tubes and
liquid-looking stucco no
yeah i've been looking all over the
place
would be squeaker
i misumi wouldn't be next to the wd-40
because that's metal works right
like what do you guys think should i
look where the wd-40 is
all right so i found the wd-40
right there
bam
but
all of that seems like it's like metal
parts like
silicone lubricant
that looks like it's for a jeep winch
which is metal
see chains all metal stuff
where can i go
to get
wood lubricant was that even a thing
graphite
dry lubricant
oh man
if no one can help me who can help me
more stuff
oh no this is all car stuff
dang it
all right so no one could help me
so far they told me get beeswax
or
get a dry bar of soap and use the wax
part and rub it and they sit eventually
the wax will rub off which i i believe
and then they'll start squeaking again
those are the only two choices
apparently they don't really make any
wood lubricant so
i'm gonna just go home with this stuff i
did buy some ratchet tie downs
don't know how heavy my dad's stuff is
but i always wanted to
keep a set on my truck anyways
and i bought some quick use ones too
see how convenient this is
my deck system
pull it out
remove all my stuff
in the back and then i could put my
blanket back here
and the reason why i want this back here
instead of inside
is before i go pick up the furniture
from my dad's house i'm gonna be
traveling with taika and geo
so we're going to have our actual
luggage inside
which is why i freaking love the deck
system because now i have storage in the
back that's secure storage it's not
sliding around
and since the stuff is already outside
i could already just come outside and
it's ease of use rather than going
inside to get something to use outside
so freaking love this thing
check them out by deck usa if you google
it it'll pop up and they have all kinds
of configurations for trucks so i got
the same size
on both sides but they have one where
one's way wider and one skinnier so you
can use all kinds of different
configurations whether you're in law
enforcement or you're like electrician
for tools some people have sick ass like
little trays where they could put all
their fishing poles or they have foam
inserts you can look like john wick all
kinds of cool stuff
and just like that we are packed and
ready to go back home but this time
instead of it being taika and i only
we got public
[Music]
yeah so of course we'll be back in two
weeks so
um
it's kind of cool like i always keep
saying i love
what's wrong with this camera anyway um
i'm horrible but yeah i love the road
trips it's a good
nice four hour break of just
mindless wandering and just driving
also not trying to die because you're
just paying attention to your driving
but that's all that's on your mind which
is really cool and i really do enjoy it
and i enjoy it with this guy
and this guy because this guy's really
fun to travel with what about the
belmont deal well the batmobile is
really good too
this guy's a cuny truck yep he's super
candy
you know it's not cuny what the gas
prices oh jesus the gospels are crazy
you
okay
yep
so before heading home we're actually at
bart's papa's house because um his
father's actually moving to vegas
uh his house is being built as we speak
so there's a couple pieces of furniture
that he wanted to bring back with
himself
jack over here is enjoying his time in
bat papa's uh grandpa's backyard hey
when you say when you see grandpa what's
the first thing you say how do you say
hi
what do you say
good job
yeah so here we have
the table top it's actual marble isn't
that beautiful
i think his dad has had it for like
40 years or something like that
it's pretty cute
actually no i take that back why would i
say 40 years it'd probably be like
20
20 plus years
oh and this is this is the color that
bart is always talking about so like
look at all the neighbors colors okay
so like a reasonable tin
a reasonable like
rust color and then bart's papa is
pink like pipto bismol pink and then
look at this green
that's what he decided to paint the
interior
interesting huh and then there he's
getting lectured
by his papa
boom
i'm looking
is this the doorbell yeah
it's like a loves pushing doorbells oh
it doesn't work
wait go open it for papa he's coming oh
you okay
doesn't fit what does he do
what does your papa do
[Applause]
i don't know how you did it but you did
it
this thing was so heavy it's not the
prettiest job this one right here how
much do you think this played
that one oh that'd be at least 100
pounds yeah this thing was nuts but you
and i we did it together yeah and i got
my ratchet set on here what'd you
probably say about me when i picked up
the thing he was like damn she's pretty
strong yeah let's go lifter let's go
yeah it's pretty sturdy got the yellow
strap on the ratchet set
so that's good now i'm just gonna tuck
this in
so it
doesn't actually
i don't know where your son is by the
way that's fine it's not a big deal
is your papa pretty happy we're bringing
it back
bye-bye
exactly
he's like i've been trying to get rid of
it for the past 10 years and i was like
damn i was using it as an excuse
okay so we just gassed up
look at the gas prices
529
diesel is six bucks 4.99 that's not too
bad i know some parts in l.a it's like
seven dollars so we got some gas and we
also got some snacks this is taika snack
this is also taika snack
mama papa snack
mama snack oh yeah
i haven't had this in forever
uh this is just general snack for
everybody i had never tried this flavor
taika saw this
he doesn't know what this is neither do
i
i don't know a good mixture of savory
and sweet and then obviously some water
what do you think i'll just say look at
the ultimate travel car there's all
these plugs so it's cutie that you do
all kinds of devices you're just so
proud of [ __ ]
um
you guys saw that i got my new usb plug
back there so now tyka's hooked up to
this ultimate road trip
yeah and he's uh tethering off of my
phone
uh for some reason my
oh my um hot spot wasn't working so
we'll figure it out ready to go yep
so dark
lunch time and we stopped by ma bear's
favorite guilty pleasure
taco bell
what's your go-to taco bell meal
it's always going to be the nachos yeah
i'm going to taco supreme you got nachos
i don't think i got nachos i didn't but
just because i always got it oh i see um
and it's harder to eat in a car i don't
know i just didn't want to deal with it
yeah oh that's true i'm gonna walk about
hands and all that matt and the chalupa
i love chalupas look at this
so flaky and soft like a croissant then
i always get the steak one oh yeah
and you also got the crunchwrap supreme
which i'm a big fan of have a bite
yeah right now no oh okay
do you like these tacos better than the
mexican street tacos they're not even
the same like it's yeah it's like asking
me if i like chocolate ice cream versus
tiramisu cake
like they're desserts but they're just
so different i like turmeric better
[Applause]
like
give me an example that has a clear like
guess i like that one better and they're
like no i can't say which one's better
no i'm just saying they're so different
so there's been alternative events
after we ate we're on the road for
20-30 minutes i got a bit sleepy taiko's
a bit sleepy and i was like hey dude
let's just both take a nap took a nap
and as i was waking up i was pulling
over because he got to leave me and now
i'm the only one that's awake and
driving
and tyka's sleeping
everyone
is sleeping
we are back home
and a ladder foul i'll take this candy
little head let me see you got a little
bumpy bump right where is it where'd the
bumper go oh right there you got a
little bump
because we're rearranging things
it's right there yeah we're rearranging
things because as you guys saw
we're bringing this hundred pound beast
and papa thinks he could do it are you
gonna do it by yourself no way i need
your help okay
i just
you gotta explain the plan to me because
this looks ridiculous so i'm bringing it
down the exact same way we brought it up
well you brought it up through the hole
yeah i'm just redoing i'm reconfiguring
it but the philosophy is the same you're
pretty confident yeah like
what is it what if you push it forward
that's what i'll be up to you
holy crap
the amount of force of it going like
this is very small it's minimal because
gravity pulls directly this way so all
the force vectors are going this way so
i'm controlling the force vector you're
just guiding it
okay well i gotta record this because i
feel like something disastrous is about
this is why
you need to take physics
and why you gotta take geometry no i was
too busy learning [ __ ] trigonometry
not a trigonometry what's the other
stuff
which is really important it is
whatever what are the other ones called
because without trigonometry you can't
triangulate stuff fine okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm [ __ ] nervous
okay wait wait wait wait i don't know
where to put it put it right there far
back over there
okay second do not touch it okay baby
thank you baby we gotta catch mama papa
failing big time
all right there we go
oops oops sorry
okay now what happened so here's the
plan i feel like i'm in the most
vulnerable position
okay
gonna lift it and bring it on put it on
the floor
but i'm burying most of the weight
unless you want to switch no [ __ ] no
okay that's it that's the plan
okay
ready wait
okay you gotta walk through it okay so
pretend okay so pretend this is plastic
how am i holding it exactly how would
you bring this down if it was plastic
yeah
right okay so that's the exact same way
bring it down as if it's plastic but i'm
i'm burying the weight you have to have
a little bit of trust here okay okay
okay yeah okay
all right ready no
okay ready okay
how did you do that
i used this
what
okay what's so important
i don't know
if you know how lucky you are to have
such a manly man even though these are
called wedges
no
good try but it's a wedge they're called
shims oh [ __ ] i knew it i know what it's
for since safety is so important we've
got a little kidney kit it's very easy
for this to just slide out see that too
yeah i know strong [ __ ] ladder i know
how strong i am but
it's dangerous so i don't want this to
come out attack is playing for it when
we're not looking or roll out hit your
car so
i'm gonna put shims in here yeah we
don't wanna um
indiana jones situation yeah so putting
shims in here so that we can keep it
protected so it won't roll out
that's all just because i know all kinds
of manly stuff you know and i know you
think i'm a [ __ ] a hundred percent why
do you have a [ __ ] i don't really think
you're a [ __ ] no no
maybe one more
it's all rolling over
what was that oh i think we turned this
on accident
oh my god
there we go yeah
see that was the same pressure now oh
wait do that again
wow
sorry dad
he probably did the same thing i know he
bent
oh god okay on that
disturbing note
what
yeah
on that nasty disgusting disturbing note
thank you guys so much for watching
we're gonna shower up unpack put a load
of nasty dirty laundry in the
uh washer call it a day
and uh get ready for tomorrow
thanks so much have a good